I'm feeling well and started to finally put some weight back on naturally.
I've considered a very short fast to help reset my cells.
I looked at the prologue therapy fast.
The prologue fast is a fine day fasting mimicking diet.
But was wondering if maybe just a simple two-day water juice tea fast might be as effective.
I've done a two-day fast.
I've never done a two-day fast, only timed fasting of 13 hours.
What do you think might be the best thing for me?
I do not want to lose weight.
From a tactical standpoint, I never recommend to fast over 24 hours for cancer patients.
I don't want to increase IGF1 levels and that can have some ill effects on a cancer patient.
I would not do a two-day fast.
The prologue therapy five-day fasting mimicking diet is a five-day specific meals that come with that diet.
It comes all pre-packaged.
Something you could choose to do or just do 24 hour fast maximum.
I wouldn't do it any more than that.
Certainly just sticking to a time restricted eating where maybe you choose to do for two or three days straight.
Or you only have an eat window, let's say, between 5 and 7 pm.
And then the next day between 5 and 7 pm.
And the next day between 5 and 7 pm.
Therefore you're only doing a 22 hour fast three days in a row.
That would be better than doing a two-day fast in my opinion.